we often talk about very old people on
this channel
what i mean by that is that we usually
talk about people who lived like in the
middle ages or like really long time ago
but we must not forget that there are
also very significant and important
figures that have appeared very recently
in history and even perhaps today that
have affected the world of religion in
in significant ways and one of the most
inspirational and impactful figures in
the islamic world in the last century or
so is the senegalese sufi saint and
social revolutionary amadobamba
he not only serves as a great example of
west african sufism or islam in general
but also as a figure who resisted french
colonialism but did so through
non-violence a peaceful approach that
was probably for that reason very
successful so let's explore one of the
most significant muslim personalities in
recent memory and the sufi order that he
started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
islam in west africa is a really
fascinating topic especially when it
comes to sufism indeed in some ways the
situation in countries like senegal or
the gambia kind of mirrors the way that
much of the islamic world looked for
most of history with sufism playing a
major role in religious social and
political life not only are these
countries overwhelmingly muslim in their
demographics
also according to pew research center
only a few years ago 92 of muslims in
senegal are affiliated with a sufi
brotherhood and the numbers are similar
in neighboring countries as well this
may be surprising to many people who
assume that sufism is some small sect
but this is what the situation has been
like or at least similar to this is what
the situation has been like for most of
history and in many places still today
as we can obviously see here it's
perhaps no surprise then why i did both
my bachelor's and master's theses on
west african sufism and spent extended
periods of time with the sufi
brotherhoods there in any case among the
two most prominent sufi orders in
senegambia that is senegal and the
gambia is the muridiya which has
significant political and social
influence and was founded relatively
recently by the 20th century figure
ahmadu bamba
in most ways the order is based on his
teachings of non-violence peace
education and an emphasis on a strong
work ethic and is still led by his
descendants to this day i actually met
one of his grandsons myself just a
little side note bragging anyway who was
ahmadu bamba then let's explore his life
and his teachings ahmadu bamba in bake
was born in senegal in 1853
in what were very uncertain and unstable
times his birth and upbringing coincided
with some very significant events in the
country primarily the gradual
colonization and takeover by france who
would come to rule the region for the
better part of a century
in other words bamba grew up in an
environment that was filled with
conflict war and tensions
the french colonial power started a
program of assimilation where the locals
were put in french schools to learn the
french language conform to quote-unquote
french culture and eventually become
frenchmen hopefully this naturally also
comes with an eroding and erasing of
much of the local traditions and
cultures
as you might imagine and as is usually
the case the senegalese people weren't
very happy with these developments and
various forms of resistance erupted
senegal at this time was a diverse place
there were many different tribes and
tribal chiefs both pagan and muslim that
ruled different regions
islam had made its way into the area
gradually over the centuries but really
started to gain a foothold when the
different sufi orders started to make
headway there in the late 18th century
the khadiri orders started spreading in
senegal and in the 19th century the
tijania also became very popular
reactions from muslim spiritual leaders
and scholars or mara boots as they are
often known there to the arrival of the
french would vary some were more
positively inclined towards the french
or at least promoted peaceful
coexistence rather than active
resistance such as the popular tijani
figure al hajj malik sea and many other
khadri sheikhs as well others however
chose to fight back in the form of armed
jihad to drive out the occupying
europeans ahmadu bamba and his family
lived in a region that became a hotbed
for this activity various
religious and political leaders took up
arms against the french and a lot of
violence erupted not only did the locals
fight the french but various tribal
chiefs and local rulers also started
fighting each other over land or
influence sometimes as proxies for the
other sides were fighting it was a mess
in many different ways
growing up amadobamba would have
witnessed firsthand the devastation and
ugliness of war and he even lost family
members including young siblings
his family were not warriors indeed
bamba came from a line of religious
scholars and his father was a very well
respected expert on the quran and
islamic law
at a young age and in the midst of all
the chaos ahmadu was given a thorough
education in all the religious sciences
memorizing all of the quran studying the
hadiths of the prophet and learning the
principles of jurisprudence especially
the maliki school of law that was most
prominent in this region he would also
study sufism to some degree but that
journey would begin in earnest later on
even though he and his family stayed out
of politics as such they were kind of
drawn into the conflict anyway when his
father was given the position of judge
and chief advisor to la jor a local king
who became one of the key and last
players in armed resistance against the
french as ammo bamba reached early
adulthood and became something of a
scholar himself he worked as assistant
to his father in this position although
later chroniclers will often state that
he was very unhappy with the fact that
his father was working so closely with a
political figure and only supported him
because of filial piety essentially
already very knowledgeable and with a
real talent for rhetoric bamba had
already sort of started having people
come to him for answers to their
questions people were drawn to him his
character and his wisdom even at this
point sources claimed that he was
showing some serious interest in
spiritual matters he would often go away
into nature for extended periods to
contemplate or to pray he had also
already started to write spiritual
poetry in arabic something that he would
become very famous for later but it
wasn't until his father's death in 1883
when he would have been 30 years old
that bamba's spiritual quest really
started for real so to say uh he seems
to have immediately sort of broken ties
with all the political leaders including
la jorda and instead went on a spiritual
journey he had already been initiated
into the clad sufi order either by his
father or his uncle and was of course
involved with sufism because basically
everyone was but at this time he started
taking this path very seriously and he
even went on a
journey he traveled away to mauritania
which was a center for
scholarship and a center also for sufism
at this time in these travels he
perfected his knowledge of the religious
sciences even more and focused
especially on sufism or tasawolf arabic
the mystical or inner purification of
the heart to reach intimacy with god he
met with many sheikhs or masters
including one of the foremost teachers
of the qadhari order and trained under
them until he himself had become a
sheikh a spiritual master but it is said
that he was also initiated into several
other sufi orders at this time too the
shadolia and the tijania in other words
he really became deeply involved in
sufism
once he had returned to senegal and his
family he did so no longer just as a
respected scholar but as a realized sufi
teacher who immediately started
attracting devoted followers
this is the start of the community that
would eventually grow into one of the
most major sufi brotherhoods in the
world
when la jorda was finally defeated in
1886 the french hoped that they had
finally stamped out all resistance in
the region and could thus complete their
process of domination in the region in
some ways they were right because it is
from this point that they essentially
held absolute power over all of what we
call senegal today but as ahmadu bamba
started to amass an increasing number of
followers and thus gaining an incredible
amount of power the french eventually
started getting really nervous about him
as his reputation spread his status
increased even more
through his spiritual charisma knowledge
of the religion and devotion to the
prophet muhammad he soon started to be
considered the
or reviver of the religion for that
century
so for context there is a hadith that
states that in every century there will
come a reviver that will well revive the
religion of islam and many of his
followers considered ahmadu bamba to be
that reviver for that century not only
this but he was also considered the
khutub azaman or the pole of the age a
title of spiritual pole of the world
around which everything turns as well as
being called the
rasool the servant of the messenger
referring to his devotion to the prophet
muhammad in particular and indeed
amundabamba had not just amassed a group
of followers in a way he had actually
started a movement a movement of
education and spiritual development that
aimed to transform its followers there
are many stories about his practices and
teachings at this time he would often go
away on long spiritual retreats by
himself he would also spend time
teaching his followers and instructing
them on the spiritual way he would also
set up his system of education and he
would write a lot
and a lot of poetry this poetry is often
very instructional so sort of
instructions again on this how to follow
the spiritual path but also a lot of
praise poems to the prophet muhammad or
to god as part of this spiritual mission
he founded two cities or villages at
that time one which was called
darussalam the abode of peace and
another called tuba which means blessing
and is probably referring to a tree in
paradise in the islamic tradition called
tuba which in sufism has often come to
represent spiritual perfection
especially the latter city tuba was very
dear to bamba
he had been looking for a place to found
a spiritual center and found it when he
was out on a retreat and suddenly had a
vision of light while he was praying
under a tree
subsequently he founded the city tuba
there which became the center of his
movement from then on he commemorated
the founding of the city with the
following verses quote oh god my lord i
pray unto you to make this blessed city
a place of peace and safety by the grace
of the prophet
i pray unto you to make this blessed
city a place of worship faith and
righteousness and a place to acquire
knowledge i pray unto you to make this
city a garden of eden for every
worshiper and a place guarded from every
outcast demon
i pray unto you to make this city a
place which will grant the benefit of
the pilgrimage to any believer who wants
to go to mecca but cannot afford it i
pray on to you to forgive the past and
future sins of the dwellers of tuba and
of whosoever visits it in search of
fulfillment i mean god o god ameen o god
the city of tuba founded by ahmadu bamba
is today the second largest city in all
of senegal and the center for his
followers even to this day
in a way you can kind of understand why
the french were a little nervous here is
this marabout or religious leader who is
gaining more and more followers and
founding cities basically out in the
middle of nowhere where all of these
followers can gather together to to
listen to his teachings
some french friendly locals in the
region reported probably accurately that
bamba could have amassed an army of
thousands of people at any time if he so
wished even though informants for the
french reported that bamba was benign
they still saw him as a great threat to
their power a marabout with this much
power could very easily turn into
another movement of armed jihad or
resistance the thing is they weren't
entirely wrong
amanda bamba was indeed engaged in jihad
even to some degree jihad against the
colonial powers and he claimed so
himself
but his jihad was not one of armed
conflict or war
instead his was a jihad of non-violence
a jihad of the soul and as he called it
a jihad of the pen
here it is useful to get a bit of a
broader perspective of what jihad
actually means because i can feel that
some of you are a little confused right
now
jihad does not translate to holy war as
i'm sure most of you know it literally
means struggle or striving and can refer
to many different things in the quran
jihad is basically never used to refer
to war or violence directly instead
jihad in general means to strive for
one's religion that can mean to strive
for a struggle for peace of being kind
there is environmental jihad that is
fighting against climate change the
sufis in particular like to use the term
jihad enoughs or the struggle against
the cell for the ego to denote the
spiritual struggle of fighting your
negative drives and ego driven behaviors
and to purify the soul and jihad can
also mean struggle in the form of armed
struggle or war for the sake of religion
which many people are familiar with that
is indeed one aspect of what jihad can
mean
and we can talk more about the concept
of jihad in a separate episode dedicated
to it but what is important to remember
here is that jihad is a much broader
term than what is usually imagined and
armed conflict is only one of those
meanings so in this way ahmadu bamba was
fighting a jihad but it was a jihad of
education and refinement of character
for the rest of his life he would stay
devoted to a non-violent cause as the
only alternative to reach a peaceful
society in this case making him similar
to other 20th century figures like
gandhi and martin luther king
the practical part of his jihad was
based on education
the movement he had started and which
was centered in places like tarus salaam
and tuba was one based on an educational
system called tarbia
it was not only a sufi order in the
traditional sense a mastery student
relationship where these students would
travel on the spiritual path to intimacy
with god it was that too but also a much
more comprehensive
system where the students were educated
in the basics of the religion they were
taught things like quran and hadith the
jurisprudence but also a deeper
spiritual education aimed at
transforming the person and society from
the inside through the sufi technologies
of the heart this would create a firm
basis for ethical human beings people
who were kind righteous and embodied all
the positive aspects of the islamic
ideals in the words of michel r kimball
quote the focus of tarbia is to groom
participants who are distinguished and
self-motivated to strive for excellence
have a sense of mission conduct a
balanced life live in peace with
themselves and their environment and
gain discernment with the necessary
knowledge understanding and skills to
make a difference in society by taking
an active role both individually and
collectively in the reform process that
seeks to better the community the
country and the world ahmed obama's
movement was also one that was radical
in other ways for the culture in the
region at the time he would take on
basically anyone as a student and
progression in the hierarchy was based
on merit and level of devotion rather
than social standing in the sort of cast
and tribal system of senegal slaves and
griots local musicians and praisingers
could become sheikhs and masters
basically anyone was welcome as part of
his movements the members of which were
known as murids a common word in sufism
meaning something like student or more
literally a seeker after god
it is also this designation that became
the basis for the name of the order that
he founded the muridia or murid order
even though bamba was a renunciate to
some degree and sufism obviously
involved a certain level of asceticism
his brotherhood was also one that
emphasized an active participation in
society bamba himself had a family and
he encouraged his followers to have a
profession to be able to provide and
nurture for their families
this was important in order to live a
fully spiritual life according to him in
particular the murids became known for
their strong work ethic and their
prominence in producing peanuts it is
true that the murid community had a
certain level of self-sufficiency as one
of its goals all of this not only
worried the french of course but also
angered a lot of the local chiefs and
leaders who didn't like that bamba was
collapsing some of the hierarchies and
sort of caste system that existed in
this region at the time and so they all
sort of gathered together to paint him
as the enemy
many of the locals reported to the
french that bamba was gathering weapons
to prepare for war and even though you
know the french sent people to
search through
the communities the community of ahmadu
bamba they found nothing but still the
process had already started that is
amadobamba was a threat to the colonial
powers and something needed to be done
about it this culminated in 1895 when
the french decided to have bamba
arrested and tried
this starts a new phase in his life a
phase when he not only passively fights
his jihad of the pen but starts being
actively persecuted by the colonial
powers and yet continues to fight his
non-violent pacifist struggle against
them
his dedication to this cause is clear
from his own statements in which he
makes it clear that his understanding of
islam and his dedication to the prophet
is what is ensuring him that
non-violence is the only correct path
as he is taken to a cell awaiting trial
in sanui the capital he wrote
each time i recall this night this
governor and the ignominy i felt like
having recourse to arms but al-mahdi the
eraser of sins and pains the prophets
peace be upon him forbade me
and quote the most worthy of gratitude
who was worshipped for the sake of his
face these texts were a spiritual
education from the living god who never
dies the one who guarded me from using
weapons against the aggressor he
indicates that in the greatest moments
of oppression and humiliation he did
indeed feel the urge to raise arms to
fight back perhaps violently but he
chose not to because quote the prophet
forbade him in other words this was the
only way for him according to his
understanding of correct islamic
orthodoxy i like this because it nuances
his character he wasn't some black and
white figure he didn't consider violence
to never be appropriate but that it was
not the answer in this case or probably
in most cases he had seen enough
violence going up he had seen how war
destroyed families destroyed people and
even religion
fighting war and using violence was even
detrimental to islam it wouldn't lead to
the spread of the religion but to the
opposite it would lead people away from
it he is thought to have said quote the
scuffles that you lead you and those
like you who attempt to wage holy war
will lead you only to an irremediable
loss despite this and strangely in
hindsight of course the french still saw
him as too much of a threat and decided
to send him into exile to the jungles of
gabon where condemned people were often
sent with the assumption that they would
not survive they couldn't execute him
because that would make him a martyr of
course so this was the best option
according to the french
but even though it seemed to calm down
his movement at first it also kind of
backfired on them
today the day bamba was arrested and
subsequently sent away into exile is
celebrated by murids as a turning point
when bamba started the journey to
spiritual perfection
indeed the seven years that he spent in
the jungles were spent in even more
intense spiritual practices which
according to murids resulted in him
reaching the highest stages of sainthood
in gabon he also wrote some of his most
famous works of poetry
in short when bamba returned to senegal
from exile in 1903 after his followers
had negotiated with the french he was
more powerful than ever the fact that he
had survived this exile was seen as
almost a miracle basically and he
started gaining more and more followers
perhaps even more so than before the
exile at the same time the french had
started doubling down on their policy of
suppressing all forms of
muslim religious leaders that started
amassing followers or that could have
any sort of power in that way their
policy was quote to prevent marabouts
from creating centers of meeting
religious proselytizing or pilgrimage
with a threat of punishment for anyone
who did they had bamba under constant
surveillance as they still considered
him a threat to their power and because
he was still getting more and more
powerful as well as the fact that rumors
were continuing to spread among his
enemies and that he sometimes actually
did show some resistance and defiance
against worldly power they decided to
have him arrested again only six months
after he had returned from gabon once
again amanda bamba was sent into exile
this time to mauritania under the
guardianship of a french friendly khadri
sufi sheikh called
this exile which lasted from 1903 to
1907 was very different from the
previous one here ahmadu bamba spent his
time with his fellow sufis he was well
respected and even started a school to
continue his mission of tarbiyah here it
is also said that it was in mauritania
that the muri diya sufi order was
consecrated fully as it is here that he
is considered to have received the widow
of the order from a vision of the
prophet muhammad himself
a weird is a kind of prayer cycle that
is performed daily by initiates in a
sufi order and which is unique to that
order or sometimes even to the
individual sheikh previously bamba had
recited the words of the qadhari shadoli
and tijani orders but now he had a
weirded of his own thus completing the
formation of the muridia into a full
sufi tariqa of its own
ahmadu bamba was allowed to return home
to senegal in 1907 and this time he
would stay for the rest of his life
he had spent most of 12 years in exile
in total but could now return
triumphantly once again
the french gradually realized that he
probably wasn't a threat and became
increasingly more accommodating to him
and the murids even so he would spend
the rest of his life essentially under
house arrest first in tien and from 1912
he was allowed to move to another house
in dior bell in his native land of baul
it wasn't tuba but at least he was home
the last years of amadobamba's life
remained intense he continued his
activities of fighting the jihad of the
soul and pen further established his
system of education which was being led
in different locations by different
shaykhs the order grew exponentially in
this period more so than it ever had and
established itself widely across the
region
he opened up new places of learning and
houses of retreats and sufi practices he
grew his family and continued to write
incredible amounts of poetry it is in
this period of his life in 1913 that the
only known photograph of the sheikh was
taken
this one
it shows bamba in his characteristic
wide attire and covering his head and
also parts of his face an image that has
come to mean a lot to his followers to
this day and will often adorn walls on
the home of murids around the world
above all he never backed down from his
non-violent principles and the quest for
peace and stability he fought his jihad
for the rest of his days with unwavering
commitment to the pacifist path
in the last decades of his life he was
on increasingly good terms with the
french even supporting them in the first
world war since he saw them as
protecting muslim lands from invasion he
had always led a movement of resistance
but this resistance was never one of
violence or even of overthrowing the
government per se
above all it was a resistance in support
of spiritual and ethical purification
but also to some degree against the
colonialist policies of eroding
traditional local traditions
he wanted to preserve the spiritual core
of society through education and thereby
create a more aware population that
would in that way resist colonial
influence
not by taking over the government
directly or something but as a gradual
transformation of society from the
inside and most importantly by peaceful
means it is thus not that surprising
that bamba did allow many of his
followers to attend french schools and
learn the french language for example
that in itself was not a problem as long
as they also had a solid spiritual and
religious foundation to stand on for his
whole career he had insisted and tried
to reassure the french that he was not
interested in trying to raise arms
against them or even interested in
worldly politics whatsoever in perhaps
the most forceful and clear statement of
his commitment to non-violence he stated
quote
whoever gives even five franks for the
sake of god will be compensated
further i have agreed to certain
conditions with god such that even if
the mahdi descends to earth i would not
assist him in battle
i will not kill neither scorpion nor
serpent nor anything that is living
according to the direction i have taken
it is absolutely forbidden for me to
shoot from a weapon such that even if
the mahdi were to revive and if i were
to take up arms my mission would be lost
bamba says in a poem quote o my lord
spare me the harm of all the creatures
and protect them from any harm that may
come from me
bamba sought peace above all and even in
his last years he assured the french
that he and his followers were not
interested in creating disturbances
quite the opposite actually bamba
praised the relative peace that
prevailed under french rule which was
much preferred to the uncertain times of
pre-colonial times which was
characterized by a lot of conflict
he even issued an official fatwa which
made clear his stance arguing that there
was no valid reason at the present time
to wage armed jihad pointing to the
specific context in which the prophet
muhammad had done so and referring to
islamic law arguing among other things
that the french rule was to be accepted
because muslims were still allowed to
practice their religion in the country
and that they being christians belong to
the so-called people of the book
oh my muslim brothers do not get
involved in the so-called jihad which
would only result in human losses and
material destruction not to mention the
havoc it would wreak in the country if
you say to me that jihad is prescribed
by islamic law and by sunnah my response
is that it was so in times and
circumstances that are different from
yours and for people who are different
from you we should treat christians the
way they were treated by prophet
muhammad they lived in a peaceful
cohabitation without any hostility nor
contempt
thus he emphasized peaceful coexistence
while simultaneously fighting very
firmly to preserve and cultivate the
islamic tradition against foreign
opposition in today's world it is
especially interesting to consider that
ahmad bamba's total commitment to peace
and non-violence stemmed directly from
his reading and understanding of the
islamic religion and its teachings just
like someone like gandhi claimed that he
took inspiration from the hindu
bhagavad-gita in his policies and
stances and martin luther king in his
civil rights movement looked to the
bible for inspiration ahmadu bamba took
inspiration in his stands in his
non-violent policies his non-violent
jihad in the quran and the examples of
the prophet muhammad ammo bamba passed
away in the summer of 1927
by then in his 70s and was buried in his
beloved city of tuba where a mausoleum
and mosque was soon erected and
eventually became the largest mosque in
all of west africa
he left behind an immense legacy
whereas the other muslim leaders who
chose the path of armed resistance were
defeated and soon forgotten ahmadu
bamba's passive his struggle was and
became more successful than anyone could
have imagined
his murid order had already become a
significant religious economic and
social force in the country and would
only become even more so as the years
went on after his death today it is
estimated that about a third of the
population in senegal and the gambia
belonged to the muridia and they play a
major role in the social and even
political life of the country
in this way he was arguably very
successful many of his closest followers
became famous sheikhs even in his own
day and their influence continued after
his passing the most famous of these is
probably the very interesting figure
called ibrahim fal one of bamba's
earliest followers who became famous and
somewhat controversial for his complete
devotion to the sheikh he would be so
devoted to serving him in fact that he
sometimes even neglected some of the
basic islamic rituals like the daily
prayers which not everyone appreciated
including bamba himself nonetheless
ibrahim fal remained a central leader in
the murid community eventually being a
sheikh himself
he emphasized a strong work ethic and
service and a sub movement within the
muridia grew out of his leadership which
became known as the bai fal the biphal
is still prominent in the region today
and is characterized by often wearing
patched colorful clothing dreadlocks and
sometimes intense musical performances
but there were many other sheikhs in the
community as well many of whom were
members of bamba's family
indeed after his death the top leaders
of the order the so-called khalifas were
essentially a succession of his sons and
later his grandchildren but the order
also consists of many sheikhs teachers
and masters of various backgrounds and
standings including of course converts
because indeed the muridia grew to be
one of the largest sufi brotherhoods in
west africa and eventually the whole
world there are communities of murids
spread all around the globe from new
york to paris and stockholm all of whom
trace their spiritual lineage to
amurobamba and his teachings of
education non-violence and peaceful
coexistence as we said earlier the city
of tuba which was founded by bamba is
today the second largest city in senegal
after the capital of dakar
it is also the place of one of the
largest pilgrimages in the world
indeed every year millions of murids
around the world traveled to tuba to
commemorate the arrest and exile of
bamba to gabon that event which came to
represent his ascension to chu sainthood
if you remember it is a massive event in
which people come to visit the city the
mausoleum of bamba and to celebrate his
life teachings and poetry
this pilgrimage is known as the grand
magal and has become one of the most
important events or happenings in west
africa having a major social political
and economic impact on the country these
practices which make the muridia stand
out are fascinating aside from all the
regular observances that all muslims
perform like the daily prayers and so on
as well as some of the more specific
practices associated with sufism the
murids have unique ways of applying the
teachings of their master
bamba's legacy in his order is not only
in the general teachings that he
conveyed but also very much in his
writings as we have mentioned he was a
very prolific poet who wrote in arabic
with a proficiency that was unusual for
someone from his region some of the most
famous of these poetic works include the
jawartu and the maglakorniran while
mafat jinan or the locks of hell and the
keys to paradise
these poems or qasidah or qasam plural
which express his teachings are
incredibly important to the murids and
make up a part of everyday practice for
them
indeed one of the most characteristic
practices of the muridia is precisely
the recitation of these poems which is
something referred to precisely as
hasadah
in a way this is the zikr of the murid
order
zikr meaning remembrance is one of the
key practices of sufism where the names
of god or certain phrases are repeated
or recited for extended periods of time
and often in groups
and in the muridia dikkur often takes
the form of hasadah recitation
murids will sit in a circle and recite
from ahmadu bamba's poetry with certain
melodies in a way it is a kind of
musical experience and a very powerful
one for anyone who has the privilege to
experience it in real life
[Music]
just like with dhikr mureeds have often
told me that reciting their claseda is
kind of like a meditation right they can
often sit for many many hours reciting
continuously and that this is almost
like a meditation that you feel
refreshed afterwards if you go to any
murid celebration especially in places
like tuba and even more especially
during the magal the pilgrimage you will
hear crasada being recited everywhere it
is a very powerful kind of thing and
it's all pervading in this region and
not just in the sound of the poetry and
so on but also visually if you visit
senegambia senegal or the gambia you
will find pictures of bamba
artistic representations of the famous
photograph or other representations of
events from his life often painted on
houses
you will see the bamba on houses you
will see him on cars
the photograph of bamba can also be sort
of hanging
in a car
he is everywhere right everyone respects
him a lot and the
visual image of bamba is also considered
to have a kind of to contain what is
known as barakah in in sufi terms a kind
of blessing right so you'll see this
image
everywhere the same is true for example
in popular music a lot of the most
popular artists in senegal or the gambia
belong to the murid order for example
the very famous artist and peace
activist yusun dur
it belongs to the murid order and he
even made an album in 2004 i believe
called santa yala released
internationally as egypt
which is an album that is dedicated
specifically to
amadobamba to the murray order and to
the sufi orders and marabouts in in west
africa in general it's a beautiful album
was actually awarded a grammy award i
think
back then and it's really worth checking
out if you're interested in the topic in
1960 senegal declared independence from
france and has since formed a very
unique political structure
the sufi orders have and still do play a
major role in senegambian society and
this is perhaps especially true for the
muridia
as i mentioned leadership of the order
has been carried on by a bombast
descendant since his death and these
motherboats have a lot of power and
popularity the murid order in general is
a significant force in society an
economic powerhouse given for example
their production of peanuts and a social
one because such a large portion of the
population are devoted to the mana boots
these dynamics has led to the fact that
during colonial times but especially
since independence senegal and the
gambia has formed a very unique kind of
social system one that is somewhat
similar to
certain earlier examples from islamic
history but it's very unusual today
in senegambia basically everyone in the
population is connected to a marabout
from one of the four major orders the
tijaniya muridia
order the marabouts are not only
spiritual and religious guides but are
significant for the social cohesion of
the people as well they can for example
support their followers financially if
someone is in trouble and other such
direct involvement with the people
thus even though senegal for example is
technically a secular democracy the
government holds a great respect for the
marabouts and they actually play a
pretty important role in politics in
fact the system in this region is one
where the secular government is at the
top but then the marabouts function
almost like middlemen between the
political leaders and the population
representing the religious and spiritual
foundation in a mutual relationship
in a way they thus have a significant
level of indirect political influence
and power an example of this is that
political candidates often travel to
tuba to ask for the blessings of the
murid marabouts before running or
also sometimes visiting them after
winning an election to thank them this
gives the politician legitimacy on a
certain level by connecting himself with
the religious and ethical teachings of
islam in the same way the politicians
will in turn often support the marabouts
and their followers monetarily and
otherwise creating a kind of symbiotic
relationship
many political commentators argue that
this political system with a symbiotic
relationship between religion and
secular politics is one of the factors
behind the the fact that senegal has
been and remains a relatively very
functioning democracy and a stable
society in many different ways it isn't
a secular model where there is a
complete separation of church and states
like in many other places which would be
very alien to
this
culture and this this region but neither
is it a theocratic model like we see in
places like iran instead it's a kind of
third option where religion and politics
do have a relationship with each other
they work with each other and they
inform each other but they are also
separated in some significant ways the
secular politicians are to some degree
at the top but the religious leaders
still play a very significant and
important role as kind of intermediaries
and and middlemen between these secular
politicians and the general population
senegal has developed its own way of
doing things which seems to be working
really well the religious leaders
themselves and the population most of
them want the
state apparatus to remain secular but
the fact that the marabouts and
religious leaders the sufi leaders still
has such an incredible influence and
power ensures that religion still plays
a very important role in society
according to leonardo a villain quote as
well organized institutions with an
extraordinary high degree of popular
legitimacy based both on an ideological
religious foundation and on the
responsiveness to political concerns the
orders have been able to provide
senegalese society with a degree of
strength in the interactions with the
state which is virtually unparalleled
elsewhere in africa a strength that is
probably an important factor in how
fundamentalist groups seem to find very
little foothold in this region and why
for example a christian leopold sengor
could be elected the first president of
the country with wide support even from
muslim religious leaders the figure of
amadobamba played no small part in this
current landscape in west africa his
non-violent jihad was arguably a lot
more successful than the violent
uprisings of some of his contemporaries
and has come to have a major impact on
the world not only this but he inspires
us to this day with his devotion to
peace his commitment to his religious
beliefs and his general resilience
whether you are a murid or not
if you're interested in more stuff about
west african islam or west african
sufism you can check out a previous
documentary i made about the tejania
pilgrimage to the city bogal which takes
place annually which i referred to
earlier in this episode i'll leave a
link to that
up here somewhere for now i'd like to
thank everyone for listening i would
like to thank all of my patrons as usual
for supporting this channel monetarily
without whom i would not be able to do
this to do all you know all these videos
require a lot of research of course now
this video was based partly on my own
research and stuff that i've researched
a long time ago this has been a subject
that i've worked with previously and
that i have some experience with but
still every video takes a lot of work of
course and so the supports of you guys
it means so much and it's invaluable to
me so thank you all so much if anyone
else wants to become a patron i will
leave links to all that stuff in the
description and in the pinned comments
but in any case feel free to leave a
comment like the video or subscribe to
the channel if you haven't already and i
will see you next time
[Music]
you